okay well thank you everybody for the
second session we're going to switch
focus a little bit we've already heard
something about molecular emphasis but I
think we're going to be hearing more
about that in the second session which
is focused on neurobiology of disease
and I think on fundamental cellular and
molecular mechanisms that are ultimately
relevant to understanding disease and
identifying new ways to treat it so and
in the middle of this session we'll have
lunch out in the atrium so we have one
speaker before lunch and this will be
dr. ke wei wang I apologize for my
Chinese pronunciation I hope it's good
enough that you know who I'm referring
to k wei wang from Peking University
will be talking about targeted voltage
gating gated potassium channels for
therapeutic potential in
neuropsychiatric disorders good thank
you and you have a countdown up there
yeah thanks very much I think you
pronounce very correctly first I'd like
to thank organizers from both sides and
I paid you and I mighty and for putting
this symposium together and also like to
send my comedy steals from both sides
and full well for sponsoring me a
attending this conference what I like to
do in next 25 minutes and like to first
and a guest give you a brief instruction
about what we've been doing in a lab and
also talk about one particular project
that we I think we advanced I think a
relative in a fast pace and then have
some interesting results before I start
to talk about the the project in the lab
I like to first ascent to other the
students and just just part of the list
and then contributed to to whatever you
need to talk about in the next 20
minutes in case I have to cut my top
shot and so and also the my clapper
eaters
at the different labs at the trial a bat
nibs and ang on lab at a hobby
University and also the yellow lab our
first affiliated a hospital and also the
Lions on labs at the academy of science
in different locations so my my lab has
has been interesting I guess can be
described as a two lines research or two
directions and first it's kind of a we
like to understand the structure and
function neurological function or four
iron channels and and those can be
summarized eyes are two different types
of are in channel the first is a
voltage-gated potassium channels and
second is a Leyden gated trick channels
and based on those knowledge that we
like to gain and then hopefully can
guide us for four next step that which
is like that the goal for the next line
research is to identify the
pharmacological agents that can that we
can useful for for future potential
therapy of neuropsychiatry disorders in
this end and we we like to screen trick
channel modulators from from natural
resources in nitro products and toxins
and and also like to also identify
compounds from again and nitro products
for 44 different like and gated ion
channel in this case alpha 7 I don't
think have time to talk about this and I
guess my my talk today is going to focus
on the last part in red and the
identification of casing q or kv7
modulators and 44 44 therapy potentials
a couple years ago we solved a crystal
structure of our kv4 in terminus and
then and then he's a zillow a subunit
called Katie one and this channel
complex it shows that this is a
interesting interaction model between
alpha circuit in blue and also the
auxiliary sub u tin in gold it can you
can see that so the interaction really
shows that shows that the two contact
points although two interfaces for the
first interface the blue part of
interviews of work k ve full income is
really sequestered by the auxiliary
stability and in the same time this
molecule interacting with a neighboring
alpha subunit n-terminus so it looks
like a class 1 molecules interacting
with the two parts of two subunits of
alpha subunit so functioning either as a
molecular clamp and because it's the
channel is so important in particular
responsible for initial initialization
of repolarization for action potentials
and they changed the shape wave forms of
action potentials and we also solved oh
this is a what happens when when the
interMune of the kv-4 alpha subunit
binds to the a cheap one which basically
the are protein subunit swings upward
and then and generating a cavity which
is for the n-terminus vacaville
n-terminus and that basically this model
explains many aspects of this Arfa's
auxiliary stability that has a
multi-function zonke rifle or modulation
we also softer the another subunit of
auxiliary subunit a cheap full a
structure the structure so very
different this is a
stereotyped image so can you can tell
that the n terminus of this a kg fully
really occupy occupies the cavity I
showed you in early in the KGB one and
showing that the if you compare with a
line k 210 pound kg 10 kg fully releases
that the difference this is a pound kt1
and then this is a first few of our
helixes occupying the cavity I was
describing earlier and basically showing
that besides if you remove the
n-terminus application for way basically
the the structures of the two auxiliary
serving identical and this cavity this
tour company can accommodate the
interminable kv4 again and because of
Katie way has has so much different
properties when when it when it by so
that came before our cable channels so
it explains a lot of unique features of
functional differences between k v kg
for a and kg one recently we also a
softer a partial n-terminal in terms of
vaca V V 3 a structure which is an
quintal may repeat although a cheap way
12 and 40 or instrument structures have
been solved by by by a lab nearby here
at Harvard so we show that this is a
internal enquiry repeat of way three
really shows that the unique difference
in critical in there in the fingers
three loops and this fingers will you
possess that's different from other
other we unclean Tamara piece that we
know so far we also intend events
because of the channel is so important
and we we also found that this channel
is particular can be active
aided by intracellular protons but not
actress ileana problems it is probably
the first trip channel that we know that
activity by intracellular protons which
has a lot of pathological
pathophysiological indications if some
if this channel can be occluded by
intracellular problems so this is inside
arpad you can see that with the
increasing concentration proton you can
see these those depending increase of
the the channel actually but not the
chain is not activated by by
extracellular protons if you record to
current from from from outside patch
recordings and as I said this has a lot
of a pathophysiological indications and
so and this intracellular acidification
then really can cause the overactive or
excessive active of this channel then
cause the cell des and but can be
rescued by if you overexpress the
dominant negative mutant in the culture
so as I mentioned and the part of the
research we in really in aspects of
translational we want to identify far
more logical or agents then can modulate
those channel particular we want to use
them in in future for 4 30p potentials
and to clarify with with a lives as a
Academy of Sciences recently we
identified many annual polypeptide and
your toxins from from Center page you
can tell that this is a forest for
instance as I'm 1a that can activate we
won and and also but not before or to a
fall and we confirmed and there's those
toxins are very selective for instance
if you'll record there's a my hotel
recordings that the I said one I can
really activate the trip we won much
much in a much much faster kinetics and
capsaicin that we know when we when we
a high first and we feel that the spicy
is because of the activation of the free
one channel but this toxin and pot pipe
does not really activate the trip ways
3v3 also are we we recently identified
another very very interesting channel
blocker 443 def def netting and this is
the plans so you can tell that if the
channel can be activated by the opener
is not quite a selective but it is open
norfolk-based 3 can be blocked by this
compound and can almost hundred percent
okay come so which is very interesting
that because so far the waste three
channel given modulators and panicking
particular blockers has not been
identified so far so hopefully we can
use this uh this compound to address
many many a question that were
interested in and how the the channel
play in the role play in in neurological
functions and also the other related
tissues so the the primary part the part
that I like to start with you is a one
of the project has been happening in in
the lab for last five years I've stay
and the guiding principle basically ties
us for this research is led okay this is
the normal action potential next
potential that we offer Miller with so
if the idea is that to everybody I guess
in all these great rikku it with me that
hypo or hyper hyper and hyper
non-acceptable it basically defines the
fundamental mechanism of the
neuropsychiatric disorders so if somehow
we can for instance this is a like to
sing pain epilepsy or secret or anything
if if we somehow can
contain this situation back to this by
activating voltage-gated potassium
channels that will probably conceived
some some potential for new therapy so
with this in mind we selected the one of
the target and that is highly expressed
in the in in the brain but not in other
tissues and this is a this is a northern
blot and so those occasional 23 a highly
expressed in in the brain and this is a
if you okay this is other evidence that
this channel controls the memory
acceptability this action potential
fired but without without reaching the
substrate the neuron does not or cannot
fire a more extreme potential because of
the activation of voltage-gated pacing
here or cave a 70 m they say the same
with meaning the same thing so because
the activation of this potassium
channels so even you stimulated sonoran
cannot fire a more intensive but if you
block it and the right arrow reduce so
and then if you stimulate you know you
can see the repetitive fire and this is
very much we can sink this is a
situation of epilepsy and pain also the
schedule secure free if you like and
this Christian cute well three channels
fixedly us six transforming domains and
lot of mutations and in those squares
and circles are identified from the
human neonatal epilepsy so a lot of
those mutants and then in it can carry
out into adults when the past 30 of
twenty percent of a patient can have
epilepsy in there later life this is a
current so just a summary of this
current and then described as a non
activating
only activating multi-decade plasm
channel and activated by depolarization
and an inhibited by am a screen
stimulation that s why it has a em call
em current it's a sustained current in
particularly in the range of action
potentials so it has a very profound
effect on on neuronal excitability it's
a it's a slow activision slow kinetics
activation the activation basically
function as a break for suppression of
repetitive the neural firing that we
showed you earlier but if you also if
hibbett this current also can lead to
the excessive neuronal excitability so
to stop to start to to screen useful
modulators we first generated stable
sorry lines expressing a single two
alone or case in q3 and to test that we
have both a target expressing cells then
we used the common and potassium channel
blockers to to to block the channel
because this is a for both a hitter
American Express m23 it's less
sensitivity years and then then kill to
along so we know we got the stable cell
lines expressing both of this target and
then we we set up a atomic absorption
relief for oxygen 9696 format which
allows us to screen a focused library
this the the principle is very simple
the routine chloride samples are sucked
into nebulizer and then into the flame
and burned to generate the rubidium
atoms and can be detected a special
wavelengths and 780 nanometers so with
this uh oh this essay is very simple I
don't want to describe more so with with
more synthesis targeted synthesis and
substitutions we came out with a with a
Ariza pyrazolyl and para meeting series
and and basically a Tesla those response
of this compound in particular alkyl 58
those depend activation of this current
and compared with a benchmark compound
called red gap in less that was marketed
in 2011 by FDA for for partial I place
partial appellees partial epilepsy and
treatment so and and then we because our
first high-throughput screening was was
was repeating flags then we we need to
test those compounds in patch-clamp
leather coat standard of this essay so
it shows that kilo 58 can dramatically
increase the current okay and those
dependently increase the current and so
this one can shift the voltage
dependence activision to the left so
meanings and then also slows down that
the activation you can see that this
frosty activate and slowly actually
meaning that the channel spend more time
in an open state and we also tested the
selectivity for for this theory with
series compound and you can see that in
particular this common can enhance a
more current for Nero Nero no type of
okv 7.2 in case in q2 so since we have
this openers and we want also want to
test if they can activate the casing
kill or native casing um channels in the
arse in around because the RT neurons
are very important for for transmitting
the pain signals so it can you can see
that yes indeed with that with a key or
58 you can see that there's a current
dramatically increased in
in in drg neurons and and also this
current can be blocked by a specific
blocker called xe9 our this compound was
a was was developed by a two pound in
back in 1980s the purpose of the having
this carmen was to enhance memory but
happened to to be now this to know that
that is this is as a blocker of the
casing huge animals and so to test the
in vivo pharmacology win first we
obviously we need to know the
pharmacokinetics and how long the
half-life of these companies when you
inject into the bloodstream and we got
about six hours for half-life and which
long enough and then Cain can allow us
to to perform the in vivo a farmer
college this is a PK profile indifferent
also the absorption in different tissues
and then the half-life I think that the
rigid it reaches the peak around I think
seven hours so we test this compound in
first in preps epilepsia models and you
can tell that this is control EEG and
this is a applied to ET induced by the
pdz there's a I Pepsi inducer surround
and this is one time and then seven
times those so for six days six six
times once a day so you can see that the
hyperactive on your activity was priced
and then this is just summary for this
compound that can really reduce the
desperate compared to ready Gabon and
all the control and also tested a
different paint models in here in
particular the inflammatory pain models
they sobriety kini induced inflammation
so you can see that really compared with
a benchmark compound and our our our Q
58 theory
can reduce the linking times and also
the increase the pin thrice of
suggesting suggesting that it has some
effect on and reversed the pen
sensitivity so this is a brief summary
and I briefly introduced that what we've
been doing back in Beijing for the last
several years and particularly focusing
on structure and neuronal
pharmacological function of a tool type
of channels ok wat ek diplomatic
channels and today I read just a focus
on a one of the type of voltage-gated
potassium channels in kv kami-sama
casing hue and the reason is that this
channel is really a prince specific and
a lot of studies confirmed that it can
be a target for for many a neurological
disorders so we started by generating
stable cell lines and screen focus like
focus library and then if I kill 58
series as a novel or leak compound and
with with two different asses in 96-well
for men and or patch-clamp recordings
and showed some efficacy in in vivo
pharmacology and then we think this is a
the compounds we identified could be to
further validate this a target is in
good use of new potential therapy for
neurological disorders and so with that
I like to stand for your attention thank
you
good well thank you very much the talk
is open for questions so I have a first
question and what other indications
other than epilepsy do you foresee for
these potassium yes I mentioned a CLABSI
pain and schizophrenia and also
attention deficit disorders and this
kind of indication for particular for
openers for blockers I don't have time
to show this and I think obviously if
you if you moderately increase the
neuronal hyperexcitability probably good
for for for memory cognition and /
before for Alzheimer disease but I don't
have time to talk about the second part
of this project which way are we are
also looking for selective blockers for
this channel and so and in the I guess
this couple of papers describing the
expression induced or expression of bdnf
when you you you have memories have a
shot long term training all you block
this channel by blockers but I don't
have time to talk about this yeah oh
maybe I'll just got some technical
question okay yep I saw the water slides
you show and in terms the concentration
is around Tim mark more that can be drug
property right we know this is a
situations that high I mean so that's
one and the other is there evidence that
this company actually is a brain
perishable yeah yeah with a with a
compound distribution that we we tested
and collect the different parts of
tissues and shows that it can pass the
BBB and for the concentration we're
talking about we compared with a drug
that approved by FDA 2011 it's a it's a
slightly lower than ratty gabon so
which is which we don't think this could
be that's there's a problem I think
there is a comparable for the
concentration that you were mentioned
not talking about in vivo pharmacology
which I show I mean that could be a
direct or indirect factor I mean in
terms of cell patch or the channel you
use a root tip to kabhi know typically
that's correct yeah right radica bnet as
a comparison I saw the Constitution was
pretty high you see around us micromolar
I think two or three and micro molars is
comparable to around 3 or 5 micro modes
for radical happen it's not not not that
far the other questions yeah we have one
over them just a very good question you
mentioned the kV 7.2 is a neuronal
specific subtype of potassium channel my
question is is this a neuronal type of
kb 72 is you picked ously expressed in
the brain regions or do you see any
bring a specific region enriched with
this subtype in one of the slides I
showed that northern blood I think from
from a group in Germany they have a yeah
it's not a in some some nucleus I think
like the to have a relatively higher
expressed and others so for this is the
amygdala that I really like to think
that I probably a play a role in mood
related behavior so isn't it's not you
be quickly a express in every nucleus
yeah it does show some some different
expression in different nucleus
okay if there are no more questions and
with thank dr. Wang again and thank you